as someone who has taught
entrepreneurship one of the things that
really excited me about the field and
about teaching the subject to our
students
is just the phenomenon of going from
something that is an idea
in somebody's head one day
into a thriving growing enterprise that
has product and has customers and has
employees
and i often tell my students that my
favorite day in one of these young
companies is the day you walk in
and a fresh employee says can i help you
having no idea who the founders of the
enterprise are because it's grown to
scale and it now
provides employment for large numbers of
people
this of true this of course is is is
very true right here in silicon valley
but it's even more powerful perhaps in
developing countries where
entrepreneurship really is
the driver of growth for these economies
as it has been here uh in in the united
states where silicon valley has fueled
uh a lot of a lot of the growth in in
our economy
another really attractive feature of
teaching entrepreneurship is that in the
entrepreneurial setting
as the general manager you really get
the picture of the entire company so
this really is a general management
function and so through entrepreneurship
you're able to see the role of all of
the functions whether it's operations or
finance
or accounting and how they knit together
together with strategies to take the
company
forward and so it really is a
a nice way to synthesize the learning
that goes on
in the first part
of the curriculum largely
in the first year
our elective courses are really
distinguished by the fact that every
single day
we present the students with a case that
we have written
around an entrepreneur
who we at the ces have a relationship
with
and and what is extraordinary is is not
only are these cases written around
people we know
but but these people actually come to
class every single time we teach the
case so over a course of about 18 or 20
classes our students will have the
experience of tackling the issues that
the entrepreneur tackled with the
entrepreneurs sitting in the class and
so the entrepreneur will get up at the
end of a one-hour discussion and say you
know
jennifer that was a there was a really
interesting point but it would never
have worked in our context
or perhaps robert you know that point
was not only spot on but i wish we had
thought about it
and so the students get the the
opportunity to practice the idea to work
through it themselves and then to get
the feedback uh from the entrepreneur
now in most cases these entrepreneurs
are our own alumni
and one of the strengths of the gsb
is this incredible resource that we have
in our alumni and our alumni network and
their willingness to come back and share
these experiences with the next and
future generations of gsb students